stranger things is the breath of fresh
air the entertainment industry didn't
know it needed
thankfully the deaf er brothers have got
us covered on March 20th 2019 season
threes first full-length trailer was
dropped and fans were more intrigued
than ever before
the trailers action-packed and filled
with tons of clues so we've started to
piece these clues together to come up
with some thrilling theories watch until
the end to find out what the fourth of
July has in store for our heroes the
first few seconds of the new trailer has
a sphere in for Dustin's life after
coming home from camp
Dustin's Electronics power up on their
own and start leading him to his living
room the March ends up being a surprise
tactic set up by Dustin's friends and
soon they jump out to scare the bejesus
out of him this proves to be a big
mistake well at least for Lucas who ends
up getting a can of hair spray to the
face the terrifying opening scene has us
laughing in no time putting our fear of
electronics at bay
well at least for now although it kicks
off the trailer in a humorous way it
shines some light on mind control and
electricity which are pivotal themes
that hour later showcased in the trailer
and seen as 11 was responsible for the
electronics brainwashed state this scene
might be hinting toward 11 sharing a
connection with Hawkins newest threat
but we'll touch down on who this new
villain could be at the end of this
video
another thing we couldn't help but
notice is that Nancy and Jonathan seemed
to have a new set of troubles on their
minds the trailer continues by zooming
into the Hawkins post storefront then it
goes on to show a very nervous Nancy and
Jonathan sitting in a waiting room
they're both dressed up and what we
imagine are their best 80s outfits
leading us to believe that they're about
to do something big in season - Nancy
and Jonathan finally came clean about
what really happened - barb I'm sorry
your timeline is wrong and we know that
they were working with reporter Marie
Bauman to shed some light on what's
really going on in Hawkins Indiana
although Nancy and her brother Mike tend
to work apart their ventures usually end
up coinciding by the end of the season
so this morose scene makes us believe
that Nancy and Jonathan are trying to
warn the world about a serious threat
coming their way however they can
potentially be putting their lives as
well as their family's lives at risk by
going public are we the only ones who've
noticed that water plays a huge role in
the upcoming season probably not
considering how often its showcased we
find out that Billy is working at the
local outdoor pool and it's packed we
later see who we believed to be Billy
taking a shower he's hunched over and
harboring a gash on the inside of his
elbow whatever caused the injury is
spreading and by the looks of things it
obviously belongs to the upside down
something is clearly happening to Billy
and things aren't looking great fans
have pointed out that characters whose
names begin with the letter B tend to be
victimized by the upside down where his
bar passed away in season one
Bob met his fate in season two so we
suspect that Billy might not make it
past season three could he have caught
an infection from the local pool if so
this means that many civilians might be
dealing with similar markings on their
bodies but what does this mean
for Billy stay tuned to find out
stranger things is jam-packed with some
pretty awesome couples but it's no
secret that there's one couple we're
dying to see get together Joyce and
hopper have had eyes for each other
since the very beginning but it seems
like their timing was never right well
we hate to be the bearers of bad news
but it looks like Hopper is going to get
stood up by Joyce if he finally mustered
up the courage to ask her on a date she
might say yes and later have her doubts
we later see hopper telling Joyce said
he wants her to feel safe but how can
she when she's raising kids on the lips
of a Hellmouth we suspect that Joyce is
scared of laying down more roots and
Hawking's and wants to move away with
her boys
sorry hopper romance might not be on the
horizon just yet
we also couldn't help but notice that
Max and xi are finally friends we see a
clip of Max dancing while Elle studies
and later see the girls run into the
star court mall hand-in-hand and let's
not forget about Billy and Karen
wheelers Brodin romance which managed to
make the trailers cut although every
stranger things character has endured
their fair share of hardships there's
one person who just can't catch a break
will Byers in season 1 we see him get
abducted by the demo Gorgon and after
spending almost a year in the upside
down we see we'll get rescued but he's
not off the hook just yet because in
season 2 will has to fight his own mind
while being possessed by the mind flare
well just when we thought that poor will
would get a chance at a normal life you
see him looking um a little feverish in
a trailer we see a very sweaty will
holding a picture of him and his friends
water is dripping onto the picture and
will looks anything but all right could
the upside down be triggering everyone
and everything that's ever come into
contact with it
if so Hawkins has definitely become the
upside-down breathing ground someone who
might get contaminated is a new
character named Bruce he is a journalist
for the Hawkins post and is said to have
questionable morals
midway through the trailer we see Bruce
walking down a dimly lit hallway with a
terrifying look on his face he's got
blood on his shirt and neck and his eyes
are fixated on something we can't see
if we didn't know any better we'd say
that Bruce isn't acting on his own
accord in fact he looks like he's been
possessed so perhaps the journalist got
a little too close to his story and
ended up getting compromised we only
catch a fleeting glance of this new
character but it's obvious that he's
going to cause problems for our heroes
at this point it's unclear if Bruce's
walking down a hospital corridor or
through the star court mall although he
may seem like a threat we doubt he's the
biggest rival our heroes have to face
come season 3 so you're probably
wondering who the big bad of season 3
really is and by the looks of it there
are more than a few new puzzling
characters mayor Kline is definitely
someone to keep an eye out for but we'll
explain why at the end of this video
for now let's set our sights on Billy
and those who could be affected by
whatever's coursing through Hawkins
water system it's possible that a few
characters will be turning into monsters
after being contaminated by the
upside-down
so perhaps Billy is the monster we see
forming in front of Jonathan's eyes
there also seems to be an electricity
monster who is showcased zapping people
wearing hazmat suits could a big beast
be escaping from the portal our heroes
previously closed
since the upside-down has ties to the
water supplies an electricity monster
could easily wipe out the town but
somehow there seems to be an even bigger
monster looming over Hawkins Indiana
just when we thought we'd seen it all we
come face-to-face with the most
frightening monster stranger things has
yet to administer no really this guy
makes the demo Gorgon look like a cute
and cuddly rabbit we suspects that this
is the beast responsible for playing
with the lights when we first see it
it's transforming in the dark here we
clearly see that Jonathan is in a
hospital setting so perhaps he was
visiting someone who had fallen ill only
to see them turn into a creature of the
upside-down the lights flicker off once
it's reached its full form and then
flicker on to reveal the monsters face
did this creature toy with the lights or
did lightning strike the sky when its
powers maxed out either way it looks
like Hawkins might be facing a power
outage and this isn't the last time for
the first time that the upside-down
has affected electrical currents after
all we'll use Christmas lights to
communicate with his mother from the
other realm now let's get to the topic
that's on everyone's mind what's going
on in eleventh life from the looks of it
she has a new best friend a caring
boyfriend and the weight of the world on
her shoulders at the beginning of the
trailer we see the gang setting up a
makeshift electrical pole so this leads
us to believe that they're already aware
that electricity is going to play a huge
hand in destroying their newest threat
perhaps our heroes are working towards
over changing in the monsters circuits
we also catch a glimpse of 11:00
standing on the shore of a very dark and
stormy sea red lightning strikes the sky
and by the looks of it 11 is in total
shock we also see 11 break through an
empty bathtub only to be submerged in
water seconds later for the first time
ever L doesn't seem to be coming out on
top could this beast be more powerful
than 11 we sure hope not
eleven might be a master at mind-control
but she's not one to use it against
people who don't deserve it for this
reason we can't help but wonder who's
controlling the civilians at the 4th of
July fair we catch a glimpse of a mother
and daughter walking towards the camera
with vacants looks on their faces so
what if the mine flare wasn't completely
destroyed in season 2 could remnants of
him be corrupting Hawkins population the
trailer ends with a series of epic
events and two or more characters seemed
to be possessed by something evil beyond
belief perhaps 11 is connected to the
upside-down beast seen as they appear to
share similar abilities could this be
the reason 11 is having a hard time
conquering her foe if so we hope she can
destroy him without destroying herself
in the process now we're about ready to
state the obvious there's something
strange going on in the star Court mall
although Steve and Nancy are no longer
an item Steve still plays a huge role in
saving Hawkins from its demise once
again Steve gets pulled into the action
without going looking for it as a new
employee at the star Court mall
Steve is officially a target after all
he's bound to notice suspicious behavior
when it's staring him in the face at
some point in the trailer we see Steve
receive an injection to the neck and
once again he's sporting his famous
black eye since monsters don't use
needles were left to believe that the
government is sedating Steve because he
found out what's really happening in
star Court mall but don't worry about
Steve we later see him hanging with the
gang and his new co-worker so the
injection might have just knocked him
out
the fourth of July is sure to bring
forth an array of puzzling situations we
assume that the fair showcased in the
trailer has been launched by Mayor Cline
to honor the American holiday however we
don't foresee the fair going as planned
with a possible storm power outage and
earthquake threatening the event it's
easy to see why our heroes will have
their hands full so we mentioned a
possible earthquake and this is due to
seeing the unknown woman falling down a
deep dark hole we can only assume that
the upside down has opened up and
swallowed whatever was in his path so
the darkness we see might be the long
drop to the upside-down realm could the
fourth of July's power supply be used to
strengthen the link between both worlds
with the way things ended in season two
many of us believed that the gate to the
upside down had been sealed off for good
however there's one person we know who
probably has the power to open it back
up in season two it's hinted that Martin
Brenner might be deceased
in fact the status on his stranger
things page says that he's very much
alive so it is possible that Martin was
given a new face after the incident and
is now the demonic mayor Cline they sort
of look alike if you think about it if
so he could have built the star court
mall as a diversion and carved out a new
entrance to the upside down and now the
star Court mall is sitting directly on
top of a new Hellmouth we don't know
about you but we believe that mayor
Cline isn't who he's pretending to be so
who do you guys think will be season
three's big bad let us know in the
comments new around here don't forget to
subscribe to the things and make sure to
give this video a big thumbs up if you
enjoyed it thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]